ام
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم نظم مؤيدو الرئيس المصري المعزول
وقفات احتجاجيه امام مقر عدد من الوزارات
و خرجوا في مسيرات في القاهره والاسكندريه
نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لنناقشه في محورين ما
دلاله تنوع الاساليب ال احتجاجيه لمؤيدى
مرسى
ومعه تلك الاساليب في ظل حاله الاحتقان
الشعبي وغياب الحلول التوافقي في مصر
تتواصل اذن اعتصامات مؤيدي الرئيس المعزول
محمد مرسي للمطالبه بعودته الى منصبه
واستعاده ما يصفونها بالشرعيه الدستوريه
واستجابه لدعوه من التحالف الوطني لدعم
الشرعيه
تحت شعار معا ضد الانقلاب والصهاينه خرج
الالاف من مؤيدي مرسي في مسيرات في
القاهره والاسكندريه
وبني سويف و نظموا وقفات احتجاجيه امام
مقر عدد من الوزارات انتهت باطلاق قوات
الامن الغاز المسيل للدموع لتفريق
المتظاهرين
وقد اصيب عدد من هم
تجاوزت مده اعتصامين ميداني النهضه ورابعه
العدويه اربعين يوما دون انقطاع المده
طويله وتطلبت من انصار عوده مرسل تنويع
اساليب الاحتجاجات لابقاء وهجره قائما في
نفوس المعتصمين تداول على منصه رابعه
العدويه خطب ودعا تو منشدون الهب الساحه
بخطبهم واغانيهم الحماسيه كما تحول
المتظاهرون الى مدعوين لحفلات زفاف في بعض
الاوقات
[موسيقى]
والى مشجعين وانصار لفريق كره القدم على
حساب اخر احيانا اخرى لم يغادر المتظاهرون
ساحات الاعتصام منذ عزل محمد مرسي يوم
الثالث من يوليو الماضي فتحول ميدان رابعه
العدويه الى تجمع متكامل الخدمات تقام فيه
الصلوات قله ايام الاعتصام وتنتشر فيه محل
بيع الاطعمه واللوازم الضروريه لتوفير
الاحتياجات الاساسيه للمعتصمين
الخدمات واساليب الترفيه لم تقتصر على
المعتصمين بل شملت عائلاتهم وحتى اطفالهم
ولم يتوان المتظاهرون في السير نحو ميدان
رابعه من امام مواقع عده وزارات بما فيها
قصر الاتحاديه الرئاسي وتعرض عدد من
المسيرات للقنابل المسيله للدموع من قبل
رجال الشرطه قد الحجاره والزجاجات من قبل
معارضي عوده مرسي بلغت اساليب الاحتجاج
على عزل مرسي تنظيم تظاهرات صغيره وسريعه
في اماكن مؤثره ك محطات مترو الانفاق
غير ان الكثير من هذه الانشطه يسبب شللا
لمظاهر الحياه في المناطق التي تنظم بها
ربما يكون هذا الشلل مقصودا من قبل
المحتجين لفت الانظار الى قضيتهم ول احراج
السلطه الحاليه واظهارها امام الشعب عاجزه
عن تسيير البلاد بثلاثه غير ان ذات الشلل
يثير احيانا حفيظه سكان المناطق التي تشهد
هذه المسيرات والاعتصامات سيما المؤيدين
منهم ل خارطه طريق الجيش ويبقى السؤال عن
جدوى تنويع اساليب الاحتجاج في ظل غياب
الحلول السياسيه القائمه على الحوار
والتنازلات المتبادله
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من
القاهره كل من احمد سبيع المتحدث الاعلامي
باسم حزب الحريه والعداله فى ميدان رابعه
العدويه و حسام فوده عضو جبهه الانقاذ
والقيادي في حزب المصريين الاحرار
والدكتور زياده الخبير في الحركات
الاجتماعيه في المركز نعم للدراسات
السياسيه والاستراتيجيه دكتور زياد عقل ما
دلاله استمرار وتنوع اساليب الاحتجاج
في الحقيقه ال ال الدلاله الكبرى هي تمكن
الاخوان المسلمين من اه استغلال ال العدد
المتاحه منهم يعني الحشد مش مساله اه اه
ادراك يعني عدد كبير من الناس دون
الاستفاده من الاخوان تحاول بقدر الامكان
ان تستفيد من الاعداد الموجوده لها تحاول
بقدر الامكان استخدام اه م م م ما يتيح
لها من اعداد الى حد ما قليله اقل بكثير
مما توقعنا كلنا ان تستطيع الاخوان ان
تحسب تحاول ان تضع اه حكومه ما بعد الثوره
في اه يعني اقصى اقصى ضغط السياسي تستطيع
الاخوان المسلمون ان اه
يعني تفعله الان
تهديد بفضل اعتصام وتكراره دائما ما معناه
الان ما دمنا راينا ان الاعداد زادت وحتى
الاساليب تنوعت
احنا شايفين فضل واعتصام من عرب المهمه
بالنسبه اكثر من حركه طبيعيه بعد ايدي
الفتره الثانيه والمواطن ال المصري ورجع
لشغله مره ثانيه فوجود النهار ده مش كمان
اعتصام اسميه اه وجود جماعه الاخوان في
بعض الامريكان لانه هو ال ال ال اه خاصه
على جماعه الاخوان وللاسف الشديد يحمل بعض
الخارجين على القانون احنا بنطالب اه اه
الرئيس المؤقت المستشار عدلي منصور بوضع
جدول زمني لفض الاعتصام بالطرق السلميه
والمعايير الدوليه
ولكن النهار ده الاعتصام وجود ومن عدم
وليس له اي معنى احنا بنشوف بتقدمه النهار
ده حمامات سباحه والعاب وواضح ان مصر انها
تكون موجوده بدون اي قضيه او اي هدف صفحه
موسى صفحه انطوت تماما الشعب المصري
المائه يوم ثلاثين سته للاسف الشديد جماعه
الاخوان جماعه الاخوان المحظوره هي فقط
الفصيل الوحيد اللي موجود داخل رابعه او
داخل النهضه
بيهتموا ب بعض الخارجين على القانون ان
هذا عندنا بعض الاسماء اللي ماتوا حضرها
وما لا ينفذ قانون ولا نفذه العداله
مستمرين هم في اماكنهم بدون اي سبب
لا يرد على سؤالي تنوعت اساليبها سواء كان
واحدا والفصيل بالنهايه لا يزالون موجودين
رغم كل التهديدات والسلطات من جانبها لم
تتح لهم وهي المسؤوله الان تمسك بزمام
الامور
بس ما فيش اي تهديدات
الداخليه
الاطفال من قبل جماعه الاخوان
بسبب استخدام الاطفال
استخدام السيدات بسبب استخدام اساليب
ترفضها الفروض حقوق الانسان ومنظمه ال ال
ال ال المنظمه الدوليه طبعا تبيان اكثر من
مره بسبب تقديم الاطفال من قبل جماعه
الاخوان المحظوره فالنهار التحذيرات الى
وزاره الداخليه طلعتها اكثر من مره هي اه
لفض الاعتصام بالطرق السلميه ما ست جامعات
الاخوان لانها موجوده النهار ده الدفاع عن
المقاومه الجماعه وليس عن الشرعيه على عن
الهويه المصريه خليني اقول لك النهار ده
كمان
الذي دفعكم الى تنويع هذه الاساليب هل هو
كانت فعل على التحذيرات من فض الاعتصام
بالقوه ام كانت خطه مسبقه بانكم سياتي
التي لحظه وتنوع ون فيها الاساليب
والوقفات والاحتجاجات والمسيرات
يعني من ضمن الاسباب التي دعتنا لا تنوع
اساليب الاحتجاج السلمي حتى يعني يرى
هؤلاء الذين يرون لا يريدون ان يروا ما
يحدث على ارض الواقع الان احد المحللين
اللي عم بيقول لك دول مجموعه بسيطه
والثاني بيقول الحقيقه مجاريها والدنيا
واشياء يعني انا مش عارف هذه الاعتصامات
الموجوده مش من الانصار ال الشرعيه او
مدعمه الشرعيه ولكن حتى اعتصامات الامن
القوات الامني في المانيا وفى كفر الشيخ
وفي
علاقه الاعتصام اللي تم يفضل بالامس من
عمال في السويس بالقوه القادريه واعتقال
عدد من المواطنين من قيادات العمال من هو
مش علاقه لا بالرئيس مرسي ولا حتى
بالاخوان المسلمين هادوا ال بردو مش مش
حركه موجوده في الشارع المصري الحقيقه
المشكله عند ال الجماعه الا بالانقلاب هم
لا يريدون الاداره انفسهم
دون ان يروا الاخر حتى عندما يتعاملون مع
اعتصام سلمي مع اعتصام مشروع تبقى الدستور
بيصير واحد وسبعين يرون بانه يعني
اليوم يعني خطا
نعم نحن مستمرون في كل
في كل اساليب ال الضغط الشعبي السلمي اه
سواء بالاعتصامات او بالمسيرات هناك تطوير
سوف يحدث خلال الايام القادمه نحن نعبر عن
موقفنا نحن اصحاب الحق ولسنا الذين
استولوا على السلطه نحن ندافع عن رئيس
منتخب يتم الان خطفوا ويعني محاوله الضغط
عليه
يقدم استقالته ندافع عن دستور استفتاء على
الشعب المجلس باغلبيه اربعه وستين في
المائه يدافع عن البرلمان تم حله بشكل غير
طبيعي ندافع عن حقه مستقبل هذا الوطن
ندافع عن اصوات ذهبت الى الصناديق خمسه
مرات ولا
من ان تستمر هذه الاصوات ندافع عن لا تعود
دوله بوليسيه مره اخرى ولا تعود دوله
تعود دوله عسكريه
يدافع عنه توزيع العقل هذه الاساليب
الاحتجاجيه الا تذكرنا باساليب تستخدمها
عاده الثورات السلميه مثلا في رومانيا في
جورجيا اه ما مدى نجاعتها في الحاله
المصريه
هو يعني الالغام الرئيسي للاخوان المسلمين
هو اه
اطالب اه من وجودهم في الشارع الاخوان
المسلمين بشكل عام جماعه جماعه عندها في
الحقيقه قدره ان هي يعني ما عندها قدره
على البقاء اه استمرارها في الشارع هون ها
الاساسي استمرارها في الشارع هو اه رهانها
انه ح يضمن لها مساحه اكبر من التمثيل
يضمن لها مساحه اكبر من التواجد السياسي
في مرحله ما بعد كده يعني مساله مساله
مطالبه الاخوان الدكتور محمد مرسي الكلام
ده كله يعني جيدي
السياسيه من الاخوان المسلمين ليس اكثرهم
يعني الاخوان المسلمين اكثر ناس عرفيه من
بشيء مش وقائي اه ولكن اه في الحقيقه اه
ال ال ال الاخوان بيعملوا اه الان هو اه
انا في اعتقادي انها معرض
لانه في نفس الوقت هم يستمرون في التوابت
في الشارع ولكن في نفس الوقت
يكتسبون عداوات جديده كل يوم سواء كانت
عداوات من فئات
الطبقات السياسيه دكتور هنالك مؤشرات تقول
العكس لما ذكرته الان اه تقول يكسبون
عداوات فيما مؤشرات اخرى تقول يكسبون
المزيد من التعاطف اه احيانا هنالك من ليس
هو اخوان وتعاطف معهم ومع قضيتهم لذلك هذا
هذا جدل لا نعرف الحقيقه فيه في الواقع
انا اريد ان اوصف الموضوع بشكل عام يعني
كونك خبيرا عن انه في حال تنوع واستمرار
الاساليب الاحتجاجيه في الحاله المصريه
الى ما يمكن ان تؤدي
هو ما هو ما هو يجب ان
فيه
في ربط ما بين الاسرائيلي احتجاجيه او ما
بين الفرص السياسيه الموجوده اه الازمه في
الحقيقه ان الاخوان المسلمين بالفعل طوروا
اصابهم الحقيقيه بالفعل اللي حاولوا انهم
يخلقوا اه مجتمع بديل رابعه العدويه ولكن
اه اصرارهم على الموقف السياسي المرن دائم
على الرؤيه السياسيه
المحدوده في الحقيقه اه
تجعل ربط ما بين ال الفرصه السياسيه وما
بين الاساليب الاحتجاجيه وقت غير موجوده
اساسا وبناءا عليه اه تصبح التطوير كل كل
تغيير في الاحتجاج ده
طيب ساعود اليك مجددا لكن السيد ربما احمد
يريد ان يعلق على ما ذكرته وايضا سيد
اسبوع هل انتم مقتنعون بنجاح اسلوبكم الا
تخشون من اه
منك متعطلون مصالحهم تعبوا
اولا بس انا اتحفظ انك تصفه بانه خبير
سياسي هو ليس خبير فلسطين ولا وليس وحيدا
هو يعني ينحاز الى موقف الانقلابيين
وبالتالي لابد ان يخرج
يسمي نفسه
ما يسمى وهو خبير في الحركات الاجتماعيه
في مركز الاهرام سواء كان مع هذا او ذاك
هذا ليس شاننا وليس شانها تفضل
نعم ولكن الك لم يوضح بعض وبعض الامر
الاخر عندما نتحدث عن حركه احتجاجيه
متصاعده ينضم اليها اه يعني مائات الالاف
من الجماهير نحن الان نتحدث عن خمسه عشر
مليون تقريبا في شهر رمضان ليس في القاهره
فقط ولكن في القاهره وباقي المحافظات
المصريه العيد ثلاثه ايام العيد كانت هناك
مليونيات دعم واحتفال بعيد ضد الانقلاب
اليوم وزارات في كل المحافظات المصريه ثم
تقول بعد ذلك الناس بالنسبه كل والناس
بتخاف من الاخوان
فيما رابعه العدويه
يجري القاء يعني اليوم بعد تقارير تقول في
اثناء المسيرات امام وزاره الاوقاف وزاره
الداخليه اه ثمنا من الناس الزجاجات
والحجاره من الصفات عليكم يعني هذا تعبير
الصور التي نشاهدها السوق المشاهد من
تعاطف الناس ومن نزول الناس عندما تم
تسريب معلومات بانه سيتم فض اعتصام رابعه
العدويه امس الاول الناس خرجت بمسيره
عفويه من
الى ما دمر العدويه الان الاخر لابد ان
يكون واضحين جدا الاخوان المسلمون ليس هم
وحدهم في هذا الميدان وليس هم المدافعين
عن شرعيه الدكتور محمد مرسي او المدافعين
عن شرعيه الثوره المصريه الاخوان جزء من
الموجودون في هذا الميدان
اكثر تنظيما ولكن الاقصى يجب ان يرى
الاخرون هذا الكلام نحن امام اعاده حمايه
الثوره المصريه ثوره 25 يناير بعد
الانقلاب الذي حدث عليها وثلاثين يونيو لا
احد يقنعني بان حسام بدراوي هو مع ثوره
خمسه وعشرين او احمد جمال الدين مع خمسه
وعشرين او فنون الحزب الوطني اللي تم
تعيين النهار ده
ثوره خمسه وعشرين ان نكون واضحين في
التوصيف السياسي والاجتماعي كل انواع
التوصيف طيب سيدي عدم الاستجابه من قبل اه
اه السلطات الان لمطالب هؤلاء تجعلهم
يبتكرون وسائل جديده
وتجعلهم
بدون اعدادا في الشارع الا يعبر ذلك الان
عن فشل من عزل مرسي
في اراحه مصر وفي تامين العيش الكريم
للمواطنين كائن من كان ان كانا اخوان او
ليبرالى او انقاذ او دائما كان
في البدايه بس العظم الموسى والشعب المصري
الاخرى في يوم ثلاثين سته اكثر من خمسه
وثلاثين مليون مصري خرجوا رافضين شرعيه
محمد موسى
اسمح لي اسمح لي ايضا ايضا من اتى بس هي
صناديق الاقتراع ثم الشعب اه تقول اه ظهر
في ثلاثين يقال الان على اذا استمرت
الامور على هذه الشاكله ما الذي يضمن ان
لا يكون هنالك اه 30 اغسطس او اي شهر اخر
يريدون ان يذهبوا سياسي وغيره ومن صور
يضمن
خلينا نراهن على جينات الشعب المصري خلينا
راهن على الشعب المصري وقدمنا معركه
حقيقيه هي الاستفتاء على التعديلات
الدستوريه وحركات شو في الشمال المصلحه
يقول كلمته في في الصناديق الزاي عشان
نسبه في موسكو لانه الشرعيه ما كانت شرعيه
محمد مرسي وجماعه الاخوان ولكن خلينا
نتكلم على ان جماعه الاخوان المحظوره
للاسف الشديد وهم لا يروا الواقع هما
موجودين الرابعه او اكره النهضه موجودين
فقط لا يخرجوا عنه بال شايفين اه يعني
التعنت شديده رفض الناس الشديد ل مسيرتهم
او اعتصامهم اللي نقوم وسكان رابع ايه
موجودين في مدينه مصر اكثر من مره العمل
وافقت الاحتجاجيه
العام لاعتصام ماذا قدمتم لهم قدمنا
المصالحه الوطنيه ال قدمنا المصالحه
الوطنيه اللي بدو يشارك فيها الجميع غدا
عن بيع القائمه شيخ الازهر معنا معناها
انه عايزين نفتح صفحه جديده حقيقيه يعبر
عن كل الشعب المصري فاتحين ايدينا ال حزب
الحريه والعداله ولكن مرفوض وجود جماعه
محظوره اه زي جماعه الاخوان بنطالب قبل
المصالحه الوطنيه انت في محاسبه لكل من اه
اخطا فى حق الشعب المصرى
تنفذها تكون جماعه محظوره كان يتحدث مبارك
عنهما ان تضع دون الكره وتكون مصالحه
حقيقيه وقياد يهم في السجون
الرئيسي غير معروف اه كيف يعني كيف يمكن
ان يطبق هذا الكلام بين هلالين المعسول
على الواقع
النهار ده في بيان جماعه اخوان بلا عنف
اعلانه خلوه منصب المرشد العام لجماعه
الاخوان الدكتور محمد بديع النهارده اقول
لحضرتك من الجامعات بيكون اعلى من الاشاره
لاكثر من انشقاق والانسحاب من شباب جماعه
الاخوان
بيعيدوا ترتيب بيتهم مره ثانيه و بيعلنوا
بجماعه الاخوان اه خلينا نرد اقول لك بردو
انه ملف المصالحه الوطنيه بدات بعض
التيارات الاسلاميه السياسيه شارك فيه اه
كلمه الان هو انقلاب عسكري او انقلاب شعبي
على الاخوان
كان الهدف منه الحفاظ على ثوره خمسه
وعشرين سيد علي انت واثق من ان يكون
سيواصلون اه حسب زخم كبير
انا بس يعني عايز اوضح نقطه مهمه جدا ان
الثوره الاسلاميه كانت اكثر تعاطي مع
المفهوم الديمقراطي من التيارات
الليبراليه واليساريه عندما نسمع هذه
اللغه التحريضيه وهذه اللغه الارهابيه
المتطرفه من احبها مفترض انه حزبها يعني
علماني او ليبرالي هذه كارثه مصر
السؤال وانتهى الوقت
مصالحه
شكرا جزيلا لك دكتور زياد حركات اجتماعيه
شكرا جزيلا لكم جميعا وعذرا على المقاطعه
لضيق الوقت الى اللقاء
ام